Колежанки Віра Олександрівна й Олена Григорівна пропрацювали
за фахом понад 30 років. Коли ж прийшов час виходити на пенсію,
вжахнулися від нарахованої їм суми.
Іноді думаю, чого - скільки років пропрацювати і заробити таку пенсію.
Я йшла на пенсію, у мене було 1800 гривень! Ось таку пенсію я заробила за 32 роки.
Мабуть, погано я працювала… Ну чому-чому..? Тому що такі у нас коефіцієнти
розрахунку пенсії: скільки не працюєш - все одно маленькі пенсії.
Зараз пенсії у обох жінок нижчі 200 доларів. Якби вони жили тільки з них,
то більше половини йшло б на комунальні послуги. Тож обидві жінки
продовжили працювати. І хоч коліжанки кажуть, що люблять свою роботу,
праця у похилому віці для них - водночас єдиний спосіб продовжити гідне життя.
Комунальні - 2,5-3 тисячі щомісяця.  Тільки дякуючи моїй роботі
я трішки ще живу. Й духом, і фізично, і морально. Ще б здоров'ячко було.
У суспільстві поширена думка, що літні люди самі винні у своїх невеликих статках.
Мовляв, не накопичували, коли працювали, і розраховували тільки на державу.
Жінки з цим не погоджуються.
Взагалі, ось ці 30 років, ось ці після… Я не сумую за Радянським союзом,
я рада, що Україна відокремилася, але дуже важкий шлях, важкі часи.
Я навіть не знаю про що б я могла тоді мріяти. Копійки отримували,
було важко, і я навіть не знаю, про що я мріяла.. Як прокормити дітей.
Були важкі часи, коли на роботі ми отримали зарплату 5 доларів,
уявіть, 5 доларів! Й іноді не кожен місяць. Які там заощадження,
які там інвестиції?! Зводили кінці з кінцями, і все.
Експерти вважають, що справа не тільки у фінансових звичках старшого покоління.
Економіст Ерік Найман наголошує, що солідарна пенсійна система України при смерті.
Треба називати речі своїми іменами. Сьогодні пенсійна система
утримується за рахунок платників податків. Але це погіршує податкове навантаження.
Тому що зрозуміло: пенсіонерам нібито треба підвищувати пенсії,
але це неможливо без підвищення податків. А підвищувати податки для тих,
хто працює в Україні - вони починають розбігатися в інші країни.
Тому що там податковий тягар легший, як виявляється.
Упродовж десятиліть кожен новий уряд обіцяє вирішити пенсійну проблему.
А саме - перейти на накопичувальну систему. Так відбувається і зараз.
Згідно з проєктом закону 2683, який чекає на голосування у Верховній Раді,
Україна має поступово переходити на загальнообов’язкові пенсійні накопичення.
Так працівники отримають особисті рахунки, на які держава перенаправлятиме
частину сплачених податків та зборів. Щоб інфляція не "з'їла" накопичення,
кошти планують інвестувати всередині країни. Найман має перестороги
щодо рішення інвестицій тільки в українські активи.
Коли починають інвестувати тільки в національні активи, хай 90-80% активів,
то вони несправедливо дорожчають, і на цьому збагачується невелика група інвесторів.
Ну ось, наприклад, якщо пенсійний фонд почне інвестувати в нерухомість.
У нас вона настільки зросте в ціні, що звичайні люди не зможуть
отримати до неї доступ…. Якщо вони почнуть скуповувати ОВДЗ
в гігантський обсягах - відсоткова ставка буде набагато нижчою
за рівень інфляції і просто буде знецінювати накопичення.
Аналітик вказує, що якщо інвестування буде неграмотним і тільки в національні активи,
то через 10 років може виявитися, що пенсійні активи не подолають інфляцію.
І люди, які начебто відкладали гроші на свої рахунки, все одно матимуть маленькі пенсії.
Позитивним моментом наразі, за словами експерта, є принаймні те,
що фінансова грамотність українців стає дедалі кращою, особливо серед молодих людей.
І все ж, студент магістратури В’ячеслав Фетісов - радше виняток,
адже вже у свої  20 років замислюється про пенсію і забезпечену старість.
Він відкрив поліс в одному з міжнародних інвестиційних фондів.
Я думаю про те, що буде завтра не тільки в контексті пенсії.
У мене планування на 1-2 роки вперед. Очевидно, що це плани,
які часто коригуються і так далі. Але я думаю, що потрібно думати про майбутнє,
і куди потрібно рухатися. Що буде через 25 років, я не знаю,
але я знаю, що у мене є така опція.
В’ячеслав каже, що завжди відкладав гроші на так звану подушку безпеки.
А два роки тому дізнався про пропозицію від інвестиційного фонду.
Вирішив, що це вигідний варіант. Тепер щоквартально платить внесок до фонду.
Там сидять професійні інвестори на високих посадах, які ці гроші
реінвестують у різні проєкти, що дозволяє отримати певний рівень прибутковості,
щоб ці гроші не з'їдалися інфляцією. Це альтернатива відсоткам в банку,
але тут трішки більша дохідність. Так воно працює, поки діє поліс.
У разі надзвичайних ситуацій, які прописані в полісі, можна отримати якісь гроші.
Окрім фонду, В’ячеслав також скуповує іноземну валюту. У парубка немає
мети не працювати на пенсії. Однак він не хоче робити це з необхідності й мати графік з 9 до 6.
Хоча В’ячеслав і поєднує навчання з роботою, каже, що для студентів
є не так багато варіантів накопичення.
Що стосується інвестування, то у молодих людей, у студентів,
ну у них обмежене коло інструментів для інвестування, тому що вочевидь грошей
у них менше - нерухомість, більш дорожчі активи, інвестиційні проєкти,
вони недоступні. Тому, можна сказати, що цей інструмент доступний
для мене був тоді і є зараз, тому я і прийшов до нього.
А які ще є способи накопичувати у працездатному віці? За словами Еріка Наймана,
спочатку треба подбати про подушку безпеки. З кожної зарплати відкладати 10%,
допоки не накопичиться 1-2 тисячі доларів. А вже маючи гроші "на чорний день",
можна подумати і про інвестиції.
Потім, коли з'являються ще 1-2 тисячі доларів, я рекомендую
відправляти чи європейським чи американським брокерам і купувати фондовий індекс.
І це робити регулярно. Вам будуть не страшні кризи. Ви накопичите
непоганий капітал з дохідністю від 8 до 10 % річних в доларах.
Експерт зізнається, що приватним пенсійним фондам в Україні
він не довіряє: мовляв, ті надто залежать від державного регулювання.
За словами Наймана, нерухомість - непоганий актив. Однак через відсутність
вигідної іпотеки в Україні, такий варіант доступний не всім.
Криптовалюта, акції в окремих компаніях - це вже ті активи,
які вимагають більше уваги й часу. У будь-якому разі, інвестиції -
це спосіб додаткового заробітку, який має бути весь час в роботі.
Всі доходи, які ви отримуватимете - дивіденди, купони, краще реінвестувати.
Чим раніше ви це зробите, тим багатші ви будете.
Віра Олександрівна й Олена Григорівна кажуть, що інвестувати їм,
на жаль, запізно. Тепер вони збирають гроші на дві речі - "чорний день" і подорожі.
Ой, хотіла би я в Париж і Рим.  Я думаю, до 70 років підлікую деякі свої проблеми
і поїду автобусом в Париж і Рим.
Якщо теперішнім пенсіонерам непереливки, то без докорінних змін
через 30 років людей на пенсії чекають ще жалюгідніші виплати.
Адже суспільство невпинно старіє, і, за прогнозами, до 2050 року
кожен третій українець буде пенсіонером за віком.
Можливо, перехід з солідарної пенсійної системи на накопичувальну
покращить ситуацію. Однак накопичення не згорять, тільки якщо регулювання вкладів
буде грамотне. Тож, аби не залишитися без засобів до існування у старості,
українцям, схоже, варто якомога раніше замислюватися про альтернативи пенсіям.